[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum i hope you guys are
having a
incredible week and i really appreciate
you listening to the podcast
uh great guest today james marsders he's
been on before but we got him in studio
and boy was he uh what's the word
forthcoming yeah open honest talked
about joss whedon talked about
all that stuff which we know was in all
over the media for some time and it
still is and uh i loved having james on
again he's a great great guest and uh
uh i'm glad he didn't get covered
because i got kovitz around that time
and he didn't get it so i would have
felt bad yeah that was a troubling time
it was but sometimes thanks for
listening i hope you guys if you're
listening for james and you haven't
listened before i hope you subscribe to
the podcast it really helps and i'm
trying to build an audience here so a
lot of great guests from the past a lot
of great guests coming up we really open
up about mental health and anxiety and
life and career and it's not just a
celebrity talk and i think if you listen
to it you'll notice that that it's just
a real conversation which i hope you'll
enjoy please follow us ryan at
insideviewpod on twitter
insidetobepodcast on instagram and
facebook that's right subscribe you can
watch the videos on youtube you can
watch the whole interview and you can
listen wherever you get your podcast and
please subscribe write a review it helps
also thanks to my patrons who give a
little bit extra if you want to give a
little bit extra the podcast if you're
really enjoying you want to help out uh
it's it's it's it's
patreon.com
inside of you
patreon.com inside of you join it's an
amazing little thing a lot of people
have become friends um from the patron
patreon
and i hope you'll join that and help the
podcast a little bit more patreon.com
inside of you also if you want any merch
uh inside of you online store great
stuff there's a there's lex luthor stuff
for god's sake smallville lunch boxes
there's inside you mugs there's a lot of
cool stuff and also if you want to zoom
me you can zoom me go to sunspin.com
that's my band sunspin we have shows
coming up october 9th is the next show
we'll be putting something up soon and
you can get cool merch and zoom with us
but uh
yeah i also will be in
west virginia this coming weekend
i'm doing a smallville nights
and i'll be signing autographs in west
virginia at the mountaineer com
mountaineer com so join me join me who
said that
darth vader darth vader said that yeah
anyway ryan did you have a good week
yes i did i mean i guess they're
listening it's tuesday so tuesday do you
have a good weekend i did you know my
rec league softball is back and you know
honestly that makes me happy it gives
you something to do it does somehow look
forward to
i need something to look forward to i
need to do more things
i think i'm going to do more things yeah
but
i realized how badly i missed
hanging out with people outside
no well if you need a player where you
let me know yeah we'll do all right cool
uh thank you for listening again and
please subscribe like i said and uh
we'll talk to you right after the
podcast is over let's get inside of
james marsters
it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
see you feel like you're uh
shooting a tv show right now you're like
how much how much do you move how tight
are you guys on this close-up i'm a
professional i'm a professional michael
you are i know
i know it's a deal
are you one of those guys that always
hits your mark that always knows what to
do that never hears from anyone
uh james misses mark again no i i um
and are we we're recording oh yeah this
is because i'm going to give you the
good stuff now supposed to be
interesting
um no i'm a guy that knows his lines
really well
uh but i don't know i'm
i'm good at the marks uh but i i do
remember um
going from buffy to angel and on buffy
we were shooting film
and they were just blown out with light
so if i was within a foot of my mark
they're like gotcha
and on angel we were shooting digitally
and so they were using a lot of bounce
for the fill light
and it was just lower light levels and
they were caught they were like james
you missed your mark gonna be off by
that much and that [ __ ] with your
performance too because you can't have
as much freedom right
exactly and i i kept thinking
these guys aren't very tight they're not
a tight crew like they should hire
people who can focus the camera and it
took me
about
nine months well six months to think
back to when i was a teenager i had a
stepfather who was a photographer and he
was talking about depth of field right
and a lower light level means that
there's a less
like a wide for those of you at home the
wide depths of field is when you know i
would be in focus if i'm here or if i'm
here there's a depth of field here but
with low light levels it shrinks
and you're only in focus if you're right
there and they they were a very tight
crew they knew exactly what they were
doing and and i went to apologize to
them and they said yeah well
we were confused james because we kept
telling you we were on a long lens and i
was like i don't know about that i just
this one thing i know
and i finally figured it out so i'm
sorry but yeah i i
i'm you know i'm pretty good with the
technical stuff i'm very good with the
technical stuff but i'm much better at
knowing my lines than
than hitting my marks although no one's
complained but no one's complaining no
one's like dude he hit mrs mark again
you always know that too because the
crew's like
yeah uh hey you gotta hit this mark
sometimes like if i'm in a real intense
scene
and uh i've gotta walk up to somebody
and i have to hit this mark and be in it
i'm like put a [ __ ] sandbag down oh
put a sandbag down because i don't wanna
think about hitting that mark i wanna
just hit that mark and just continue
with what i'm doing you know what's the
sweetest thing is when the actors are
giving printable takes and the crew is
blowing them i love i love that when the
crew's blowing them well you know i mean
like
yeah i mean like there can be any number
of mistakes on any take and there's all
sorts of yeah hey blanche quiet
blanche she understands english did you
hear that you hear her barking now she
gets it she just probably would you hear
another bark ryan yeah he did
quite michael but
when the crew blows you no no i mean no
no that's actually uncomfortable no this
one
it's when it's when the actors are
giving printable takes but the crew is
the one have to say i need another one i
know and you know what's funny is
they're such like
they're geniuses i mean most crews i
worked were fantastic and they just
they're perfectionists so that takes
probably fine it's like ah it was a
little soft yeah you know you can cut to
the other person yeah on for for a
second you know we didn't talk about
this the last time you were on you're
such a great guest and you were so open
that
i'm glad you're back i'm glad i'm glad i
didn't really prepare anything because i
was like you know i just wanted to talk
to you but there's a couple things like
for instance you know your transition
into angel now was that something that
they approached you early on did joss or
anybody say hey we have these plans for
you to be on angel were you were you
surprised that they're they want you to
be on angel
uh
they
he came to me
uh
it was certainly before we finished
filming buffy it was before the the the
summer
uh it was a few months before so yeah i
had some lead time
uh
and apparently they had gotten cancelled
and joss was trying to going back and
forth with network well it was cancelled
angel angel was cancelled and season
going into season five so after season
four they canceled it and joss was like
well what if we do this can i can i have
another season what if i do that and
then he found when he said what if i can
get spike they were like oh well if you
can get spike you can you can go for
another scene and so he called me did
you know that he needed you or did you
not realize that i didn't know that
dynamic that would have been a thing
called leverage
uh
well i found it out and yes
and it helped
it did but um
it took a long time
and it it taught me
to not be angry
with producers when they tried to screw
me
that's so hard because you take it
personally yeah and and uh i i thought
back to the days when i was paying
actors
uh when i had a theater company we only
had 60 seats so it's the same problems
but in a smaller right i paid people 18
of performance and but that's what you
had yeah but that's
what they had
and do you think that's see that's what
they tell you they had well here we go
here we go so
um
i
i held out for the amount of money that
i was making on buffy i i because josh
said we don't have a lot of money on
angels not like buffy we it's we have
some money it's not a cheap show
obviously but it's not the same as buffy
uh
and i i i told him i said look when you
told me that i said i'm not going to
hold out for more than i was making on
buffy but you're offering me less and i
didn't really
that didn't think that that was gonna
happen and i'm not really gonna gonna go
for that right
and charisma
uh got a phone call saying that we we
can't have you in for the season five
which was very painful for her and i
have to ask myself did i
in me
holding to that amount of money mean
that they had to make a decision and and
shrink the cast
so they didn't bring her back for season
five yeah and
partially probably to pay me
so you feel bad even though it's not
your fault you were just getting what
you were thought you were worth it's
called business yeah exactly i mean
obviously it's it makes you think oh
[ __ ] i hope that
she has a kid
did you ever talk to her about that yeah
you did yeah and what did you say to her
i didn't you know i mean she knows she's
part of the biz she doesn't you know
hold any grudges or anything but uh
but i i have a feeling that that
obviously you know that's if i was
signing the checks that that would be my
thinking we can only afford these many
actors and if i could have gotten james
for half price i'd go to charisma and
see if she could right for half price or
whatever and maybe we could keep
everybody around but no
but you're right about you take things
personally like it's hard to go on set
where you're working in that atmosphere
and separate
business from from you know you're there
to also the crew they're working their
ass off they have nothing to do with
this the other actors have nothing to do
with this but there's this resentment
that fills inside of you
and you start to think i'm not
appreciate appreciated i just they they
don't really care about me they don't
you know so what do i do value me so
it's hard i i remember tom welling said
because i was going through
renegotiations and i remember you know i
just was like
they just made all these promises
and they just didn't keep them
and so he's like hey you know i see how
upset you are
like you're not your fun self you're not
doing stand up to the crew you're not
hanging out you're just going to your
trailer you're delivering your lines i'm
like
but they don't care
the business side doesn't care as long
as you're delivering your lines they
don't care how happy you are so don't
let them dictate
you know oh wow you know what i mean
your happiness and that changed my
perspective in a lot of ways
like you know i started thinking you
know well what do i do well what you're
doing right now is just punishing
yourself
you're like i'm not worthy and i'm
did you go through any of that
i was playing a character that was
pretty much unhappy all the time
and i was like i was super like uh mr
method actors so i was getting consumed
by this character and i was getting in
touch with all the darkness and
loneliness and isolation the whole time
uh you were really method on for spy
yeah and i gotta say it's dangerous like
the method can be used for film because
you're in and out for a specific period
of time which is usually less than a
year
and uh when you're doing it for six or
seven years it just keeps eating you and
you just keep climbing in especially
with a character like that jesus when
you say method what do you like explain
for the audience what you mean for a
role or a series what are you doing that
makes it method yeah so the method gets
a kind of a bad rap because people you
know uh it can mean
anyway it basically don't get out of
character you're that guy forever yeah
and and you're you're trying
you're just building
like i was building a little tiny town
in my mind called sunnydale and then
that little tiny town was a little tiny
buffy and it was a little tiny spike who
loved buffy but she didn't love him back
the way he wanted her to and and i i i
provided all those details so that in a
in an imagination imaginative way i
could kind of escape into that and it
seemed real
uh
sean penn calls it the box
meryl streep calls it the
i think the sandbox or the playpen but
it's the boundaries it's that it's it's
the boundaries of sunnydale you know for
for for buffy
um
and it means that once i escape into
that reality once i'm fully kind of
believing it right you know you're not
psychotic you don't really believe it
but you you you have this detailed
imaginative life um
you can just kind of move within that
and in and once you're sunk into that
you
in a way can't make a mistake whatever
you do is kind of appropriate because
you're really living living that life
like um
uh daniel day-lewis who does this a lot
when he did um
lincoln
well everything everything everything
there's one uh that he uh uh scarlet
letter
and he was playing a quake quaker i
think um early protestant of some kind
uh he
he's playing a guy who is a carpenter
and so he went to the set very early and
built his own house
and he learned carpentry and he lived in
that house viggo morrison slept with his
his horse for lord of the rings
so that there was a reality being built
that you really can't act and when you
watch daniel day lewis
in that film the way he uses his hands
is a workman
because he is now and the way that figo
morrison was was uh the relationship
that he had with this horse because he
played a ranger who's all about his
horse that relationship was real so he
provided that it didn't have to be acted
it just was and so it's very useful for
film because it you know film is so
intimate that it catches acting acting
is basically lying right now it really
is hungering for an a real doc a real
event to happen to document
and is not really satisfied with
anything less
and so
the more that that that i can provide
myself either through imagination or
through actually doing it um
the less i'm acting and the more i just
have it right uh but it ate me for buffy
it just ate me a lot yeah because films
for like a better word ephemeral you
know it's sort of like
you know it's these four months
it's this six months it's three months
it's whatever it is but a series is
so you don't know when you're gonna get
it yeah and i guess you know with the
hair and stuff you you kept the hair i
mean obviously it's your hair so i saw
some interviews you always went on with
the colored hair and you they'd have to
redo it every so often
and
in a way that helps you kind of keep
that character with you doesn't it i
mean if you want to think about method
it's like you're carrying the character
with you home at night yeah
inside of you is brought to you by
nitsa
it can be a little frustrating folks
especially if you're in a hurry or
you're running late to find yourself at
a railway crossing waiting for a train
and if the signals are going and the
train's not even there yet you may feel
a bit tempted to try and sneak across
the tracks
well don't
ever to the naked eye trains often
appear to be further away and moving
slower than they are and they can't stop
quickly even if the engineer hits the
emergency brakes right away it could
take a train over a mile to stop over a
mile to stop and by that time it's too
late and the result is a potentially
deadly crash the point is you can't know
how quickly the train will arrive
the train can't stop quickly even if it
sees you it ends in disaster
if the signals are on the train is on
its way and you just need to remember
one thing ryan
stop
trains can't stop trains can't
brought to you by nitza
inside of you is brought to you by
wandery
even the rich
mariah carey is one of the most
successful singers of all time but her
rags to riches story isn't exactly a
fairy tale on an all new season of even
the rich you'll hear the astonishing
story of mariah carey's rise to fame and
the heartbreaks and trauma she survived
along the way
billboard named mariah carey artist of
the decade in the 90s
she won five grammys sold more than 100
million albums worldwide but in the late
90s it all came crashing down leaving
the world to wonder would she ever reach
the heights of pop superstardom again
even the rich starts with mariah's rise
to stardom when she used her
extraordinary once-in-a-lifetime musical
talents to escape a dangerous upbringing
only to find herself tied to music
executive tommy mottola the man who
helped make her dreams a reality and
after finally finding the strength to
leave mathola in 98 mariah stumbled and
struggled to rebuild her career to prove
herself and the world that she truly is
the greatest singer of her generation
even the rich has the roller coaster
story of mariah's rise fall and come
back and this is really a great comeback
story and you know you always see again
celebrities how they are but you never
know the struggles that they went
through like the regular folks do like
we all go through in life so i think
you're gonna really love this listen to
even the rich on apple podcasts amazon
music or you can listen ad free by
joining wondery plus in the wondery app
did you feel like that did you feel like
with whoever you were with at the time
your loved one was like your spike dude
for most of the time i didn't i
i just went home i was alone
the whole time
really yeah i was i would just go into
my crypt i would drive home and be in a
little tiny apartment study my lines or
walk on the beach alone because that's
spike
and i didn't i didn't really
consciously do that
i just realized that all of my stage
acting was not really working very well
for film and i had to try a new way and
i guess i just without consciously
making the decision just decided to just
step into the character and to feel that
way but it was a it was a lonely time
really depression yeah
yeah personally speaking it was
it was not the happiest time of my life
why is that exactly
well because you know the character of
spike is all of my darker parts this the
side that i try not to inflict on the
world
because like being a nice person is
really the act of
not telling everyone what i'm thinking
all the time you know
very true uh
trying to give people the best of me not
not not the worst and um so spike is
spike is all of the the frustration all
of the uh loneliness all of the um anger
uh that i have in me and you don't wanna
you don't wanna have dinner with that
guy that guy's not fun so you aren't fun
to be around for seven years correct but
jesus but you know you combine that with
the script which is delightful and funny
and sparkling and everything and that's
the character of spike
um
dynamic
yeah you know i mean like that's true
with any character you know you you
bring what you bring and then you add
the script to that and that's when the
character happens um but uh no i mean
the best thing that i did was i
i just didn't talk to anybody on the set
i was known as the ghost really yeah i
didn't know that so you really didn't
talk to anybody you kept yourself no no
i knew nothing about what was going on
around me i like i would freak out the
crew because when they said when they
say second team on a set for those of
you at all that means that you actors
can go [ __ ] off for a while yeah uh and
when they call first team that means we
want you back close to the set right uh
and so when as soon as they called
second team i would just go and
disappear so you never ate lunch with
people for the most part you never
conversed with them about it unless it
was about a scene and how you were going
to work it yeah yeah so you were you
were approachable you were there if
someone needed you but you just didn't
prefer being around people yeah and i'm
i'm remembered as being like the very
nice guy in the set you know i wasn't
like you know being a dick or anything i
just wasn't really hanging out with
anybody and so what i would do is i
would lot i would find a little dusty
corner of the set
within earshot of the first a.d and lie
down and rest close my eyes
all the time
all the time and if i heard either james
james marsters or uh first team i would
just appear on my mark
and the director or the ad will be like
james whoa jesus we no we didn't call
first team we're just talking about you
not
you know you must have heard it over the
wall
yeah the first team's been a real bunch
of houses
yeah they liked you they did you think
probably you always have you always
think about what people think about you
that's what we do i mean that's what i
do i want people to like me
we all do right but did you feel like
the cast likes me they think i'm a
weirdo all the above
i think i understood that they're both
were true i think they i think
they liked me uh i was easy to work with
um i didn't i didn't come in screaming
you know i didn't didn't have did you
ever get upset did you ever lose your
temper i got upset a lot i didn't lose
my temper
uh i would go back in my trailer and
throw things sometimes you would oh yeah
but i wouldn't i wouldn't so nobody saw
it no no
you'd scream in your trailer you'd have
to you know what you'd have to ask them
you can't recall because you know you
only remember the things that make you
look good so i
really
i got i'm pretty confident
also in you know what i see i see the
cast at conventions or we call each
other and they always reflect back that
that was always really easy to work with
and i like they like me a lot so i think
i'm probably right i you're probably
kept that nice i think it would have
come out by now that you were a real
dick
um yeah i also saw that you know i know
that you did a lot of love scenes or
with sarah michelle geller now she's
obviously adorable and she's great and
you're working with her and you're
lonely and you go home was there ever a
time where you're like i've got a little
crush on her i wish she liked me
the opposite
really the opposite yeah so the opposite
yeah like you didn't have a crush on at
all well i had
so spike is alive in me
and spike is in love with buffy right so
that's true
but
for for many seasons we weren't in love
and i came to think of sarah as my kid
sister who i loved very much
and who drove me crazy sometimes and i
know that i drove her crazy sometimes of
course uh and and we're you know you're
working on a tv show and you're all
nobody gets sleep and you know and so
you see the best and the worst in people
and i and i was like i like my kid's
sister but ah i wish he would be right
right um
uh
and so when they said uh i remember i
went to i went to joss and i was like
look if you ever want me to take my
shirt off can you not mark belucas me
and just give me some give me some lead
time because i can give the difference
between having a body looks good in a
t-shirt and the body that looks good
without one is just a mountain to climb
so just give me a little time to get
ready
and
and he goes oh well i'm glad we're
having the conversation because uh uh
get ready over the summer because next
season you and uh you're gonna fall in
love with buffy
and i was like
great idea dude i've always thought that
that was the answer because the whole
the whole
the whole truth was is like if you're
gonna put spike in the show as a as a
cast member right you gotta you gotta
have him
stop trying to kill buffy in some way
because that was his whole reason for
being
uh but
if he keeps trying
he either succeeds and we don't have a
show which obviously you're not gonna do
or he keeps failing and that's just
gonna get repetitive and ridiculous and
i always thought they put a chip in my
head which meant that i couldn't even
kill a fly and that was funny but i
thought a better idea was to have him
fall in love with buffy of course she
never reciprocates that would be
ridiculous
but you can see you could you could have
him try to win her love either to and
fail either to horrific effect or
comedic effect and you could run that
one in many different ways and that you
probably could could put together some
seasons on wow and so i just assumed
that was what it was doing and he goes
oh no no no if she's going to fall for
you too you're going to have sex so get
ready i was like what
i just couldn't concentrate that would
have excited me like i would have been
like oh my gosh that's great i mean as a
professional of course but still
i mean you know
it's you know people always ask you know
how is it like doing
make-out scenes or sex scenes i'm like
it's work it's not fun at all it's like
you know but
if you're attracted to someone and
it's not it doesn't suck
i'm i'm gonna be a liar if i'm gonna sit
here and go well it's all you know when
i was kissing uh christian crook it was
it was just it was like kissing my
sister it was gross i was like [ __ ]
then i'd be a [ __ ] liar
she's a beautiful woman and i was it was
it was it didn't suck
well this is what it just did not suck
that's all i'll say yeah this is what
happened so so uh i i have this problem
i know i'm gonna have to fall in love
with sarah and falling in love with your
sister is a weird thing to be asked to
do right now and uh i went in and she
was shooting a a scene where she's uh
selling burgers outside the
drive-through and she's got this
ridiculous hat on
uh for for her job
and her character has just saved the
world obviously um died gone to heaven
and she gets pulled back by witchcraft
back down to earth
earth in comparison to heaven is hell so
she's in hell now she wakes up and now
she's got this magical kid's sister
out of nowhere that now she has to raise
because her mother has died boy this is
complicated so anyway
she's in the [ __ ] right and she has to
she has to provide
for the kid's sister and uh so she's
working in this burger shop and she's
the frickin slayer she's
she's like superman having to sell
burgers for a living and she's not
bitching about it and she's trying to be
nice to rude customers and she's being
really really cool about being in this
horrible place and so i'm watching her
film to see
and i fall in love with buffy
wow and i was like that's my end
i just found it i got it oh my god i
don't have to fall in love with sir i
love sarah but not you know right and uh
and i was just sitting there kind of
like this just looking at her with misty
eyes she turns around and goes what
not you too james everyone's been making
fun of me with this hat i didn't think
you would to god that i broke her heart
and i i couldn't tell her no i just fell
in love with you baby no no i just fell
in love with you i mean my character
fell in love yeah
it's so it sounds psychotic but that's
what it is and and yes and so i i very
much enjoyed
kissing her because
when i was kissing her i was spike right
and again that imaginative world allowed
me the license to
to admit that yes she's a very good
person to kiss but
all right good answer good answer that's
a good answer you know but i hate i hate
love cd yeah i don't like him either i
just feel uncomfortable because i never
feel like i'm sexy i never feel like i
look sexy no matter what i work out for
a month i'm like hey you're still rose
and bomb you know you're not that you
know
i don't know i just i i'm
but i can do it i can turn it on if i
have to and hopefully they'll cut around
it and make it look sexy and they'll add
some like portis head it's just
it's a it's a it's usually a glamorous
scene they want it to be glamorous in
some way and the word glamour means
illusion so it's very far
it's it's it's far away from reality so
the shots have to look so good
that it takes a lot more work to create
something that is far away from what's
actually happening so
the more glamorous it is like oh go in
and kiss her oh i love you about it
james you are one quarter inch too far
to the left can you just move your mouth
can you turn a little bit nope too far
okay do it again oh i love you no james
breath mints sprinkle on set please yeah
and so it's just
such a highly technical
thing
uh it's just very hard to act in and
then you're usually freaking naked in
front of a lot of people who are not and
that's everyone's nightmare that's
everyone's had that yeah mary you're
naked and everyone else has got clothes
so it's just it's like and what is my
job description this morning when you're
brushing your teeth
you know you just admit it
yeah
inside of you is brought to you by
better help boy this company has helped
so many people it's helped me it's
helped ryan here uh if you don't know
about better help just listen up if
you're dealing with any kind of
depression anxiety
work overload you got a lot on your mind
you just need to get it out um ryan
we've talked about this you're still
doing better help still doing better
health still helping you you seem like
in better spirit i'm not just saying
that but you you can tell better help
helps you get better it really does it
really does and i like these guys
they've stuck with me because i think
it's working i think people are
listening and you know i noticed a lot
of my patrons you know they'll respond
like hey betterhelp's really cool thanks
thanks for introducing me to it and um
it's just one of those
sponsors that's it's not even a hard
sell it's like you know it's so easy to
like do you want to feel better about
yourself do you want to
fix things that you don't like about
yourself better help better help is
there if you're feeling depressed or
struggling with uncertainty or having
difficulty sleeping better help offers
experienced therapists who can listen
and they can help and you can start
communicating in 48 hours or less
there's a broad range of expertise
available which may not be locally
available in many areas the service is
available for clients worldwide you can
log into your account anytime send a
message to your counselor and you'll get
timely and thoughtful responses plus you
can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions so you won't ever have to sit
in an uncomfortable waiting room as with
traditional therapy better help is
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they'll make it
easy and free to change counselors if
needed you know if you have did you have
to change a counselor i did but that was
only because he left the service oh he
left the service okay well there you go
i mean that's the thing you meet
somebody a lot of times you're like
i'm not comfortable with this person
right it's so easy you just change
they'll help you change immediately and
and this is common this happens you
might meet the therapist of your of your
life
you know but you will you'll find the
right one uh it's more affordable than
traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is available and that's
for damn sure um so many people have
been using betterhelp they're recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
don't even take my word for it just do
it take ryan's word for it if you want
because uh
we really believe in this in this place
better help online therapy and here's
all you have to do it's pretty easy
inside you is sponsored by better help
online therapy and our listeners get 10
percent off their first month of online
therapy at betterhelp.com
inside
that's better help dot com slash
get matched with a better help therapist
and get started inside of you is brought
to you by
chirp
the chirp wheel is unbelievable you're
talking to a guy who has back problems
uh if if any of you know it having back
problems or uh neck problems or anything
if you know what those things are you
understand that there are certain things
in the world that make things easier
that alleviate the pain the chirp wheel
my friends
is here for us and it is the most
comfortable wheel i've ever experienced
i roll on it there's three sizes i'll
tell you all about them take it from me
someone who suffers from back pain many
surgeries
it works you just use it and i use it
every day
chirp is a brand dedicated to helping
the world feel good so they can do more
of the stuff they love in other words
chirp is all about feel good do more
to do this chirp creates simple
innovative and effective pain relief
prevention solutions chirps started with
a revolutionary wheel for back pain but
they just are getting started
and uh it's something i use every day
these these wheels they're you know
the the bigger you get the small ones
are good for your your lower back and if
you're not that mobile and you can't
move around too much you start out with
the small you work your way up to where
you could bend with the medium this is
how i operate ryan have you tried the
trip wheel ryan i think it worked great
did you feel comfortable after using it
did you feel like i'm stretching you out
a little bit oh for sure yeah i i really
love this thing i've seen other wheels
and they're just hard and they're they
just don't feel good on your back these
things molds to your spine there's like
this little divot
that you can you just it just fits your
spine right in there and you roll it out
it's really really miraculous chirp is
all about helping people feel good and
do more back pain prevents millions of
us
millions of people from feeling their
best when they don't feel their best
they're limited as to what they can do
and chirp can help fix that with chirps
patent pending spinal canal and three
different pressure options to choose
from chirp will help your back feel
better so you can be back to doing what
you love in no time it features
many things such as three different
pressure sizes gentle medium and deep
spinal canal to comfort your spine as
our wheels give your back a unique
four-way stretch each wheel can hold up
to 500 pounds they can be nestled
together for easy travel to take
wherever you go and i take them
everywhere i go when i go to do these
signings at conventions i bring them
with me i lie on the ground i do a
little roll out
and i feel good as new they are
certainly uh an amazing accomplishment
the chirp wheel thing i want to say
thank you to chirp wheel for uh helping
me and many many others in this world
who suffer from chronic pain
visit go chirp.com that's go
chirp.com and enter the promo code
inside and you're gonna get 10 off site
wide that's go chirp.com and enter the
promo code inside to get 10 off
site-wide
you know look you've talked about this
you said what you said there was a lot
it was it was a big thing with joss
whedon on set
and you know the whole
um
way
castmates were treated was it something
you were privy to something that you
noticed something that or was did you
always just feel like he was just a a
tough guy knew what he wanted was
intense what was it like for you you're
i'm not saying that you're you don't
agree or you agree with whatever
everyone had their own experience
i'm not going to tell them they didn't
exactly that you're not telling what but
your experience i want to know your
experience my experience because i
remember you telling me in the first
interview that there was a time where i
kind of put you against the wall and
said something to you and that was like
you know
i said
he was joking and you go no
so maybe just recap that briefly but
then go into what your perception was
yeah so uh just
in in josh's world evil is not cool and
i really respect him for that
vampires were just a metaphor for the
challenges that you get over in your
adolescence so vampires are supposed to
be overcome
and uh he got talked into one
sexy vampire that's not going to be
killed off that was angel and i was
supposed to come in and get killed off
and
uh the audience immediately reacted to
me in a way that that made it
was gonna make it very difficult to kill
me off and the network was telling them
oh my god keep this guy in the show and
all of that and he's like you're
i was basically
ruining his show
basically forcing him to keep you on
because you were doing so well
yes but the thing is is that
that is going to change the show from
being about a teenager overcoming
adolescence
into a show where
where those problems are kind of sexy
aren't they all those
all this this this psychotic
i was killing people all the time i was
shredding them and the audience was
going oh we want more of that and josh
is like no no the point is that you
overcome the evil that's the point so
if i was in his shoes i would have
killed me off i wouldn't have pushed me
up against the wall i do wish i just
would have killed him off immediately
saying i know i told you five episodes
will pay you for five but you're dead
after two sorry that's what i would have
done but he didn't do that he didn't he
just got frustrated and figured it out
but there was that day when he
he pushed me up against the wall how did
it start did he immediately go up to you
i don't remember i was i don't remember
it's it you know i just have people
there
yeah yeah and and he's in my face he
goes i don't i don't care how popular
you are kid you are dead you are dead
you are dead you got me but you never
were dead but he didn't yeah because he
so you didn't make a slight smirk to it
there was a but you're dead
no i just said it's your football dude
you got you did you want
you know i'm not i'd come off of
producing so i was always on the side
i'm always on the side of production so
yeah uh uh but your experience on set
like that you can remember like you're
sitting there and you're in your head
because remember you just told me you're
kind of a loner you're kind of doing
your own thing so i don't know what you
saw but there were peripherally where
they're kind of little things that
you're like oh that's pretty intense or
that's
two things first i kind of i kind of
thought of him as a mad was like as a
wizard
like able to create magic and here's
another amazing thing but also like you
know don't piss off gandalf because he
might you know smile yeah or i don't
know snap well
tell you exactly what he's thinking you
know but i just remember one time i went
up to him and i said you know
it must be wonderful to to to wind up
this universe and watch it play out
it's not exciting and he goes yeah it's
great james except i have to keep
winding
and so he put an enormous amount of
pressure on himself and so i i saw his
his uh
intensity
as that as as trying to accomplish
something that was a very high bar and
that he most of all
put
the pressure on himself to deliver that
um
and
the other thing i want to say is that
i was mostly angry at him that he wasn't
around
by the time i got because i i
you know i was he was around for my
second season
and i was in 10 out of 22 episodes of
that the third season i was in one
episode by season four when i became a
cast regular and was around all the time
he was off doing angel
and by the time i was on angel he was
off doing firefly so
he was never i he just you never saw him
really and this is the thing though this
is why i was mad because when he did
come around and and and direct an
episode
i i was never in it i was like the
musical well that is a yeah i had a
couple of scenes in that i think i had
two scenes in that but oftentimes i was
i knew that i'd have the most time off
if joss was directing for some reason
when he came on i just wasn't very much
part of do you think he didn't like you
that's what i thought that's what i was
just like do you still think that do you
still think he never liked you no not
not anymore no uh it's just that i think
that his mind went to the original
conception of the show which was his
scooby gang going through
uh machinations and overcoming things
and that you know
i'm a purist by nature as well so i
understand that his mind kind of goes
back to the right
kind of thing uh but at the time i was
like
you know
so the truth is is there was a lot that
went on that i that i that i didn't see
really you just didn't see it you would
hear about things probably yeah and the
the thing is that that that spike
usually
spike's storyline was kind of like a
miniature movie within the other movie
within the main movie it was a subplot
so most of my scenes were with guest
stars
i didn't have that many you know
i had scenes with the other cast members
certainly but but not all the time a lot
of times it was it was with
another cast telling a separate story
would you do a buffy uh reunion if they
did something
or a buffalo movie you know if if jos
yes if
i i i have i have
i have reticence about it mike because
you know spike is a vampire and i'm not
you know oh spike looks really good for
his age that's that's not what you talk
about a vampire like what the great
scene would be buffy and spike get back
together and spike looks exactly like he
did back in the show but they haven't
been they have makeup you can look a
little younger they you could look they
could use things for
you know i mean you still look damn good
but you're not like you know you're not
20 years ago i know but i mean like that
would that would be amazing to see buffy
have to deal with that one like spike's
still beautiful and buffy has aged like
that is that's a great scene but that's
sort of what would happen in the vampire
world right the vampire stays young yes
yes that's
sleep all day party all night never grow
old never die it's fun to be a vampire
and to take and to take any of that away
from a vampire character is to diminish
them so
i'm that's my reticence that's why i'm
kind of like
i'm maybe the one character where you
could do you could do another another
buffy and see all the characters and see
how they were doing now
with spike it just you take them down
off of what makes them cool to begin
with just by having me in there so it
might be it might be best to recast it
do you think it will happen
i don't think people have no idea no one
wait a minute go back you just said uh
recast someone well they would never
recast you
they would never
i mean they've replaced me
so i don't know
what they haven't replaced me on like
but on smallville but they have
used other lex luthors but there's
you're a spike yeah you're a spike from
buffy yeah i felt really guilty about
doing that by the way really when were
you lex luthor oh [ __ ]
oh yeah you were the voice it was just a
voice for a car what do i care about
there's been hundreds of though i don't
know
anyway i was i was not bad
i'm sure you were great now i'm gonna
listen to it on what what was it on
it was a cartoon called uh doomsday hey
[ __ ] you dude
all you had to do was call me and get
that average uh video game uh called dc
universe online
yeah but the the thing that i was
thinking when they offered it to me was
like i don't know
if
i don't know if i can have fun doing
this character because i know that
michael rosenbaum did something no no no
no seriously like like okay
i would never want to do rebel without a
cause
because james dean did that perfectly
he i'm never going to be a better
i don't know the name of that character
in that film
i don't know ryan looked at me like
don't ask me
hudson hawk maybe i don't know whatever
it was i'm never going to be a better
version of that character he aced that
one so that just leave that alone
conversely i am not sure how good james
dean would be doing spike
there you go we all have the things we
all have the things we do all right he'd
probably be freaking out if he was if he
was cast as spike like brian james
actually did very well on that i don't
know if i'm gonna be able to to you know
make it sing the same way so i was i was
just thinking man like i don't
i don't know if i can have fun with it
because i'm always going to be worried
that i'm just i'm just down here where
it's already you know everyone knows
what can be done with the role and now
i'm going to be you know not that so
look i'm overpaying me so yeah i'm
always happy when i hear some oh how is
the voice of lex luthor of course i go
well i just don't know why they didn't
call me but you have a different voice
than i do and you could do maybe a voice
that they wanted or they wanted to i
this is this is acting this is the this
is the world i don't i'm like hey man
people like what do you think of jesse
eisenberg i almost said jason what do
you think of jason eisenberg i'm like
good for him
hey man you got lex luthor hey i wish
you the best dude i worked with him he's
a really sweet guy he's talented [ __ ]
yeah yeah i'm always rooting for people
deep down do i go why don't they ever
give me you know why wouldn't they even
give me an audition for it why would
they test me maybe
who whatever reason that's the only
thing that i think bothers me mm-hmm i
was like did i was like did you like me
on that show did i do a great job and if
the answer is yes then why would you at
least let me say let's see what he does
for this well this is the thing that's
the only thing that you know this is the
thing bothers me as well so when i was
when i was doing theater i talked about
that too much but it was it really was a
a a formative time in my life i would do
a lot of auditions
and then out of this audition there's a
small group of actors that i thought
were
really really good
and that was my treasure chest
and i held that
that was
the way i made money you know and i
would try to add to that treasure chest
i would i would audition hundreds of
actors and i might find one more and i
put that in the treasure box but when i
cast i went back to that treasure box
and i find that
the best directors you see they do that
they bring them back tarantino does it
score says he does it a lot of the big
gilbert if you like somebody and you
like working with them and you think
they're a good actor
then you
work with them again hopefully and and i
think that you know we lit we're in a
very large market here in los angeles
there's millions of us so there are a
lot of very good actors
but i'm not sure
how many people in town have that
mentality rather than the one of there's
so many actors i will find
the one that fits
the image that i woke up with this
morning and they will and they'll punch
all the buttons and they often find
someone who will
fit that but may not be
as good of an actor frankly uh i
remember i was directing a um a play
called uh life is a dream great play
it's known as the spanish hamlet uh
um and this guy uh robert sindler
uh who is an incredible actor
great
director [ __ ] guy right
with an l problem he his l is a little
bit back in his quote like that right
and he wanted to play the the prince who
starts as a deadly
villain and then becomes a heroic
romantic character it's an incredible
role and he wanted that role so bad and
he and he came up to me and he goes and
he knew that i was not probably going to
cast him and he and he goes let me ask
you a question james
what is it is it more important to have
a good actor in the role or someone who
fits the role and i said well robert
it's kind of a it's it's a balancing act
try to get both he goes [ __ ]
and i'll tell you why because when you
you are going to direct this thing and
you're going to go
off and perform at the larger theater i
know your schedule and your and and your
customers going to be alone with your
actors and they're going to create the
product
and do you want a really tight actor
delivering these words or do you want a
lesser actor delivering these words
and i took that to heart and i cast him
and he was the best thing in that show
the best thing in the show and work
ethic new newest part inside out
everything everything that it takes to
be a good actor he just checks all the
boxes i think a lot of times nowadays
they go
connie or john how many instagram
followers do they have
3.9 million okay that's good um what's
his imdb rating oh okay
um there's a lot of things there's a lot
of variables that go
with that but
i kind of say you know i try to be at my
age i just kind of think i'm just
grateful i'm just doing my thing i'm
loving you know life as best i can and
trying to navigate through it that i
don't have time to think about why they
cast other people we both lucked out on
a level
this is all we did who gives a [ __ ] i
mean who gives a [ __ ] if i could say if
i'm 90 years old and i say hey you know
i did this [ __ ] i did this role in
this role and like what have you told i
always say this if you told your 10 year
old self you're going to do this and
you're going to
you he would take a [ __ ] right there on
the street like
all of the the miracles that had to
happen to us dude like just coming in
town and getting any agent yes any agent
is like
the biggest miracle in the world to to
to get any real job
through that agency is uh we can easily
be working at staples right now oh my
gosh wherever we could easily and by the
way i really like staples and i would be
horrible at i was the worst waiter
god awful it was the only other thing i
could possibly get hired for yeah there
was nothing else i could get hired for i
got fired from so many jobs because i
was just i was just pathetic i was
horrible maybe because you were
miserable because you weren't doing what
you loved for whatever reason man i was
just not the one you wanted to give you
the ice water how long were you on
torchwood
only two episodes you just did two
episodes two and they gave me a freaking
action figure dude and i only got two
episodes and i actually got resentful
about that were you mad that they didn't
bring you back from yes i was like i
rock come on yeah they all yeah and i
did and you worked with john barrowman
oh i loved it yeah did you hear what
happened just in the news today no
john barrowman has opened up on why he
exposed himself on the set of torchwood
claiming it was up to him to keep the
cast entertained
the dancing on ice judge has been at the
center of uh
anyway his behavior on set of blah blah
blah they came to light this year and
accusations of sexual harassment were
made by his former co-star uh noel clark
[Music]
all i could say on this
and you know him too is he's a
flamboyant kind of larger-than-life guy
i'm not saying any of this is okay or
whatever but you know he kind of just
he said he stated like you know i had a
sex scene
on the show and so i just try to make
people comfortable by just being naked
and running around and like there's a
certain flamboyance and openness and
whatever
and
that can certainly backfire which it did
so i just was wondering if you
experienced anything like that
and and the thing is that he is such
this is my experience and i can't speak
to the gentleman i don't know who was
harassed i don't know exactly what that
entails obviously he had a very
different reaction to or different right
right right take that away from him but
what i experienced was
a a man that was
so sweet and so supportive so loving so
giving
uh that nothing
about the behavior and i've seen his
penis
nothing about his behavior made anyone
feel uncomfortable it it it it
nothing
[Music]
which is not to say that i mean i would
say that
his behavior was was was inadvisable in
that it could be taken wrong by some
people you know
you never know who you're going to upset
who you're making uncomfortable
and so i'm sure you know we all we all
live in the decade that we live in and
we all learn from each other and we all
are each other's mirrors you know uh
sartre said that in no exit we are each
other's mirrors and we we
we judge what's acceptable by what other
people are doing and we learn from that
and and now in this decade you know i
remember doing runaways and the first
day of work was meeting with the lawyer
uh though you know hundreds of people in
the theater and the lawyer talking about
uh what we do now in hollywood and what
we don't do around sexual stuff
and i remember thinking oh thank christ
he's like thank god we're going to get
all of the there's rules now and we can
all kind of be comfortable together and
there's not going to be all this drama
anymore thank god you know
but that's not when when i shot
torchwood was before all of this stuff
was was uh
given to us by lawyers before all of the
people knew it was made mistakes and and
and we're learning together
and so i i tried for myself i try to not
judge people for not knowing what we
know now
um and not saying you should have you
should have been where we are now
10 or 15 years ago right uh it's not
that long ago but at the same time it it
it seemed
very risque but also sort of acceptable
at the time well you heard robin
williams on the set of mork and mindy he
would run around naked constantly really
and he wasn't doing it too
in a sexual way and again i'm not saying
i'm just saying if you know robin
williams and you look at robin williams
and he's running oh look at me i'm naked
and he's like oh my god he's in he's
he's out of his mind yeah he is that's
he's an eccentric person
and it's better if we don't do that
stuff and we know that now we know that
now right yeah back then he's you know
but it is it is better i'm i'm here to
say i was much more relaxed on runaways
than any other show because of this
because of me too because of all these
that we're teaching
you just have to yeah and you know and
so if he could go back in time he
probably said
keep the pants on today john you know he
probably would do but i have a sex scene
i know well whatever it was i mean the
person got uncomfortable and um
you're right though you make a good
point it's like we know now
it's like well no your behavior then you
should have known
we all make mistakes we've all said
things that we regret we that we're
human beings when are we gonna get a
break if we really apologize and want to
be a better person yeah and it's it
you know even historically you know i
think because we're looking back now on
uh on political figures you know
especially the founding fathers and
we're we're really coming to terms with
a lot of them had slaves
you know and we're recognizing
um
and and i i think that slavery is the
the
one of the worst things that humanity
has ever come up with uh
350 million people died of slavery
that's that's a lot of blood in the
ground man and we're still dealing with
that yeah and we're recognizing that
there is a there is an inherent
hypocrisy between the documents that we
started with and the behavior of the
people who wrote them
absolutely and i have to think of
how is my generation going to be
thought of
in 100 years
and they're going to look back at our
behavior and say they were monsters
what what are those issues
you know and i think the way we treat
animals the way we treat the planet
and things that i can't even 100 years
will we be here
that's the thing
there's stuff that i'm not even
conceiving of that that we're going to
be judged on but i'm a part of my time
i'm doing the best i can i'm trying to
to to be a moral person
with what i've got now yeah i get mad at
myself because i think
i always think i'm doing the best i can
and i'm like are you though yeah
are you [ __ ] really doing the best
you can are you doing enough charitable
work are you doing enough no you're not
you're just not
good you're doing what you can
no
by the way how are you doing i mean it's
been a has it been a rough year for you
oh no pandemic
bag of shells well yeah it's been tough
it has been tough for everybody i mean
everybody's had their time but uh how
are you holding up i
very well i gotta say are you yeah yeah
i i uh
i'm a gamer so
i was like
oh i have to stay in in in oh this is
such a change i'm going to stay in my
bedroom and play video games like it's
just
okay i get to do more of that right
uh
you know i mean it was scary and uh um
certainly the convulsions in the country
uh were scary as well
uh so there was some stress eating i
won't lie yeah you know um
but you know in general um
my family's doing well i'm doing well
we're both
everyone's still here i'm very lucky
um
most of my friends are still with us and
what's wrong what's uh what's what's
next are you working on anything i know
you're always working on something
you're always writing you're trying to
produce things you're yeah
uh and what do you want to do
i don't know man i i i'm hoping that a
i shot six episodes
of an update of upstairs downstairs in
napa valley
uh during the pandemic um
and i hope that that gets picked up it
was really weird they decided to shoot
six pilots six episodes uh and i think
it's because they had a they had a
really good relationship with warner
brothers and they really were being told
that they had a very good chance of this
getting picked up uh on one of the
streaming platforms
um upstairs downstairs yeah that was an
english show about an english manor
where you have all the rich people on
one side you have all the servants on
the other and there's a gulf in between
and they're all human beings
and we recognize them as full human
beings even though there's a gulf and so
this update is the rich people are wine
growers and ranchers up in napa valley
and the servants are the latinos who
work the land
and there's a gulf but they're all human
whether they recognize it or not and i
just thought what a genius update
especially right now
to to kind of make that point like we're
all human beings no matter what the gulf
is we're all human beings here
so yeah yeah but i hope that gets picked
up and i get to play a douche bag you
know for a change really
yeah it's good on you yeah that's
success
they gotta be lovable it can't just be a
douchebag
hey this is uh [ __ ] talking with uh
james marsders these are from my lovable
patrons you could join patreon
patreon.com inside of you and uh i'll
write you a message after you join
supports the podcast
um he's a rapid fire or whatever you
want kelly s
which fellow cast mate did you become
closest with
in buffy
tony uh
amber benson
amber benson yeah what is said tony head
but amber benson because we did chants
together which is a movie that she wrote
produced directed and started and she
asked you to be in it yeah
wow and and uh i came to respect her
deeply because i i produced on a dime
when i was doing theater it was not
expensive not a big budget and she did
she she got a really good film out of
almost nothing and she was so smart
about how she approached the entire
process uh so yeah i came to love and
respect her very much maya p what is the
most rewarding moment of your career
there are so many there's so many my god
how can i choose between my children
michael
myself there has to be one
no
that's hard that's hard that's a hard
one uh
okay well i can just pull
stuff that i've enjoyed and there was so
there was a uh
uh uh i did a six-hour original play
about the french revolution and six hour
play this is back when nicholas nickleby
was popular and i was in chicago and
stand up in an hour oh it was so
delightful it was it was so we spent
like the normal six-week rehearsal
process getting the first three hours
ready and we opened that and then the
playwright was struggling with the
second part he was supposed to deliver
on opening night so we could start
rehearsing opening night of the first
three hours deliver the second three
hours and we'd start rehearsal
at the same time and he didn't and uh we
had about a
i think we had about a week and a half
to two weeks to rehearse the second part
before we put it up
and uh
and that was stressful and i was playing
the lead and i was just basically on
stage the whole time six hours of lines
yeah yeah and and and and people would
cycle in and out and and uh i remember
kind of freaking out and then we go to
open the second half
and we have no rehearsal you know and
and all of the the the lighting
cues get dumped out of the computer
and we have all of the critics oh
because the first half was a kind of a
hit and and everybody was really excited
about the play and so all of the major
papers the chica the tribune was there
all of the big uh people the sun times
was there
waiting and uh we don't have any light
grids and that the thing is that all of
the the visuals for the play we're all
lighting because
we're we're changing um
you know we go from france to england we
go you know here and there and you can't
change out sets so it's all different
lighting and it's very complex lighting
it's all gone
and the director just comes backstage
and he's like well
we're just gonna bring up the house
lights so they can see your face and
let's let's go guys we gotta go we got
and you did it like that and we did it
and we got a huge standing ovation
and i realized
if you have a good script
and you have actors who know what to do
with it
you can create a product and you can see
their eyes
and there's just enough light to see
them
you can create a product that's that's
worth money
uh
in theater you know uh that's great that
was that was pretty good that's the
highlight this is interesting jason b
what are your thoughts on technology
advancements that allow actors to not
only reprise their roles with their
youth restored
if they wish but can actually allow
stars to be in films and shows after
their death how do you feel about all
that well first like carrie fisher or
like we were talking about making you
look younger a spike
if you prefer i don't think we're there
yet
i don't think i have not yet seen
a credible instance of this happening
legolas in lord of the rings didn't well
how about uh brad pitt tarantino film he
looked younger
and you know what oh yeah yeah him and
dicaprio right yeah they definitely look
younger they definitely uh that one did
work and
they're improving they're all improving
and also
irishman was the big one
oh yeah you know what though that kind
of bothered me i didn't like it i didn't
like it carrie fisher i didn't buy i i
didn't even buy uh the new luke
skywalker even though i wanted to be
mandalorian yeah i kind of gave in
well that's i was that's exactly what i
was gonna say like i was so invested and
so excited in that moment that that i
was like i don't care i'm there anyway
but if i'm really honest about it the
technology
as impressive as it was it's just not
quite to the point where i am not
i'm just i don't know i don't have to
cross any gulf to to to buy in right so
but we're going to get there what's your
favorite show on tv right now or what
are the shows that you're watching
you like games
see i just can't keep up ever since it
was just
i like up down left right red button
it's it's hard for me that's easy for me
but i i like to be an interactive part
of the story where i can decide i'm
going to talk to you no i'm not well
what game you know uh right now i'm
playing um the new assassin's creed
again because it's so beautiful uh i
have that but i just i i can't even i
don't even know what i'm doing
it's so hard i'm like i just wasted four
hours my neck hurts and i haven't moved
an inch
i just put it on here it's so hard just
put the difficulty on easy and whoop up
on it
my favorite game of all time is
wolfenstein ii
because is that like a castlevania kind
of feel
no it's a total ups the original was
probably like that it was a first person
shooter and you just basically you know
a long time ago shot a bunch of nazis
but this one
uh is about
what if germany won world war ii
and then came and invaded and took over
the us
and
half of the u.s is just fine with that
oh
boy so it's like kind of in a way the
civil war it is another yeah that's you
know what i mean and it's it is it's a
way
uh i from wherever
of admitting where we are as a country
just split down the middle yeah and uh
and you get to go down
uh
i think it's in in louisiana
and you there are people running around
with hoods
white hoods and you get to shoot them
and it's you do everything what's this
called again a lot uh wolfenstein ii the
wolfenstein one is amazing great game
and it's again about killing nazis but i
like the nazi idea of killing nazis
that's it's always fun i always love
nazi movies i always love you know in
glorious bastards i always love
documentaries about that stuff i'm
fascinated by it because it's such an
astonishing time in history that i think
you're just
it's like
you can't get any more evil than that i
mean you can but
yeah well that's the thing is how can
you get how can you get the audience
comfortable with killing people and you
know the if you can get someone really
villainous then it feels good you know
yeah and so that just on a conceptual
level of of of uh having me look at in
my own country in an honest way and also
just it's fun to kill people in hoods
i'll be honest
by the way leanne p asks i mean we
talked about the controversy regarding
buffy and your fellow cast mates but
have you have you reached out to any of
them
after all that um
i reached out to sarah
uh and but that was just texting
um
that's it i put i put out a again you
know i feel like i'm
i am uh i i put out like on twitter and
facebook i put out support right you
know uh
you did yeah towards the cast members
yeah and and sarah couldn't believe it's
like you didn't know about that stuff
going on and i was like
i was just thinking about me i'm sorry
i was just into character you know she's
like oh yeah you were that guy yeah
uh um
but but that's it yeah that's it really
yeah but you would do a buffy reunion
you said you would
if if a script could come that would be
delightful
uh that could incorporate the fact that
spike has aged can't vampires age if
they want to well can i gain a few years
because i loved you so much buffy that i
aged a few years to be
or he's just he's just cannot accept the
fact that he's aging that he's just i
look horrible
oh my god
i'm just falling apart because he's like
at this point 150 years old he's at 130
years of not aging at all and suddenly
oh my god jesus you know spike you look
fine for my age
you know that would be kind of hilarious
but it would have you know it would have
to be on the page that would have to be
dealt with in a way that was very very
delightful it was boreana's cool to work
with yeah you got along really well you
didn't really hang out nope didn't hang
out but worked well together always
always well in fact he i was really
jealous of him in the beginning because
my girlfriend told me that she had a
crush on him so i hated him but he was
nice to me from the very beginning like
he was the one to go over to my little
trailer and say hey man uh can i show
you where the bathroom is can i you know
this is where we keep the coffee and and
you're doing so well i imagine the same
thing is going to happen for you as did
for me which is i started out in the
exact same trailer you're in now a
little triple banger and now i have a
bigger trailer and i suspect next year
you're going to you know you're going to
move up and and how nice so nice all the
time that's good a good leader yeah yeah
and and uh he was just a workhorse on a
on angel
you know that's awesome yeah i remember
i i there was one episode where i was
the lead on angel and he kind of i think
he had the week off
and uh i just got toasted and i came
back after shooting that we was monday
again we were starting a new episode and
i just sat down next to him i was like
how do you do it man
i don't how do you keep showing
seriously how do they do it i don't i
don't ever want to be the lead on a
one-hour series on especially network
television
i i just don't i i'll never do it yeah
and i say never i'll never do that i
would never do that i just can't stupid
enough to try but i don't i i i kind of
hope i'm never asked it would just be
the death of me michael rosenbaum 55
years old dies on set yeah of absolute
exhaustion yeah i don't want to be that
guy rather
i'd rather be the interesting guy who
gets the morning off you know yeah yeah
yeah but be the third thing that you've
lost lead fifth league come in there's
kill it crush it leave see ya let's do
it let's character actors character
thank you uh last question
your audition i think we might have
talked about this but was the accent
your idea or was it they wanted someone
english they wanted someone in english
they they they uh uh they did you tell
them you were english or they knew you
weren't english no they knew i wasn't um
and and he wanted an original london
punk rock vampire that's what he wanted
that was did you really work on that
accent no um i got the audition
the the day that i auditioned i think
that there was four days until filming
they had their backs up against the wall
they've been looking for someone for a
long time and hadn't found them and so
the call i guess went out around town
scraped the bottom of the barrel you
know
and they found me down there
so i i pulled out the accent that i had
uh just from doing plays you know i kind
of have a workable
you know
accents that i would get cast as you
know and so i had a good enough one to
audition with and remember the lines
remember any of those lines that you
first said the first words you uttered
on maybe not edition or uh or maybe your
first words on buffy you were there if
everyone
who said he was at woodstock was
actually no if everyone who was at
obviously not well
hang on you were there you were there
you were there if everyone who said they
were the crucifixion actually was there
it would have been like woodstock
you know
that was the first thing that was one of
the first things that's the one i
remember
that's such a good accent though i mean
people applauded that didn't they they
loved the accent yeah it got better i
mean like if you do anything for six or
seven years you're gonna get pretty good
if we decided to juggle i imagine
in seven years we'd be really good you
know so did you find yourself on dates
going yes i like um a large glass of
did you ever do that did you ever
accidentally jump into oh i'm so sorry i
remember one time i was with a
girlfriend in canada who's also an actor
and we decided to have english accents
just walking around a mall we got
invited to three parties in half an hour
are you serious
wow they really do like english people
yeah well this is a treat i like i like
being in person with you i'd like to see
you and talk to you and i'm so glad
you're doing well you look great you
look better than you did last time i
just had surgery so i don't look that
great but i'm doing fine yeah
everything's great okay yeah okay what
kind of surge that was a little back
surgery they just went in there and they
took some things out that didn't belong
in there and now i'm just healing but uh
should be uh good to go very soon kick
ass well you look like you're still
doing sit-ups which is impossible i'm
not really doing sit-ups ryan's laughing
he's like he's sit-ups
sit down he's doing sit-downs
uh james mars thank you for allowing me
to be inside of you once again this is a
treat you're so kind when you're inside
thank you
a great guest
really good
really good um
just enjoy he's one of the few guests
that don't say hey cut this out or he
just says what he wants he knows what
he's saying he doesn't have any regrets
and he says it and i like that it makes
our job easier doesn't it he does he was
really uh easy to talk to and i i really
appreciate you james jimmy
for coming over you're welcome anytime
you're a really fun guest to have on the
podcast
and again join
patreon.com inside of you that's where
you can go to join patreon and become
one of my top tier patrons or just a
someone who's giving a little bit more
back to the podcast go to patreon
patreon.com
inside of you and don't forget the
inside of you online store if you want
any merch or go to sunspin.com it's my
band
you can zoom with me you can get merch
there for the band we've got some really
cool shirts and hats and a bunch of
other things steven amell has been
wearing my sunspin hat on every
interview on anything he's been doing so
if you want a sunspin hat that stephen
amell's been wearing go to sunspin.com
and if you want steven the mel's hats uh
tough
exactly tough tough um
yeah i really appreciated james coming
in it was fun yeah it was good it's good
to have people in again why don't we
read our top tier patrons and uh just a
reminder to subscribe and follow us um
on instagram
at insideepodcast and facebook at
insightypodcast and at insideofupod on
the twitter write a review do all that
stuff help the podcast out will you
folks and i'll be in west virginia this
coming weekend to do a small night
signing autographs taking pictures uh we
can talk about the podcast talk about
anything you want i'm also on the cameo
so you can cameo me so let's do the top
tier
top tiers here we go big shout outs
nancy d leah s trisha sarah v correct
little lisa yukiko jill
brian h
mama lauren g correct nico p jerry w
robert l jason w apothean kristen k
amelia o allison el raj c joshua d emily
s cjp samantha m jennifer and remember
you get your name shout out if you join
patreon.com inside of you this is what
the these are they get their names shout
out because they're top tier patrons i
shout their names out
stacy uh l correct jen asked jamal f
janelle b carrie b tap of the 272. not
beginning
i just met her she was at the lexington
con and it was a joy oh nice she was a
sweetheart oh um someone's calling me
not answering that one kimberly e mikey
eldon soprano 99 more ramirez santiago m
sarah f chad w leanne p janine r maya p
matty s shannon d belinda n kevin v
james r wow that's hard when i go random
chris h
dave h spiderman chase sheila g brad d
ray h tabitha uh t correct liliana a
michelle
m
n k k michelle king
michael s talia m betsy d
claire m laura
you're making faces of me and i don't
know what it is
l
chad l rochelle nathan e marion meg k
janelle
n lorraine g carrie h veronica k big
stevie w
yes kendall t angel m rhiannon c corey k
super sam coleman g dev nexon michelle a
liz l jeremy c andy t cody r sebastian k
gavinator and h david c elliott gould m
john b brandy d yvore r camille s bono
orbano the c the c
joey m willie f christina e in adelaide
and
adelaide and those are the top tier
patrons folks i love you listening every
week
tuning in i know there are a lot of
podcasts out there but hopefully you're
enjoying this when you learn something
from it helps you out in some way thank
you for all your letters thank you for
all your kind comments
and um you know we're still doing it so
and thank you big shout out to my uh our
editor here jason jason doing a great
job when you say ryan i think he's
kicking ass uh he's doing a great job
doing a great job ryan thanks for being
here with me of course
and uh ryan helped me today we did a
podcast and he had a good uh
question for one of the guests and
interjected at the end and i'm glad he
did i told him to interject whenever he
wants i remembered something you
remembered something and i appreciate
your remembering
your memory you're welcome um thank you
bryce i love you buddy and uh from
myself michael rosenbaum and myself ryan
tears up here in the hollywood hills of
california waving at the camera thank
you for allowing to be inside each and
every one of you and i hope you have a
glorious week be good to yourselves
um
and that's it i love you thanks
[Music]